why do you feel that now is the right
time in your career to take this leap of
faith and join celebrity big brother
why do i feel like this is the
uh time in my life to um
to take the wish to take the jump and
join celebrity big brother well i think
i'm at this time in my life where
i'm you know i'm promoting myself as
much as possible
um you see this money making right here
so why not be on celebrity big brother
in front of millions and millions of
people
to show my personality
so you know to let people come into my
world
it might pay off
sorry about that i'm sorry as a
celebrity you're accustomed to people
watching your every move and living
under a microscope are you ready for the
public to see you in a different light
watching you 24 7.
yeah this is a little different from the
reality tv that i did
um
you know whenever i was tired i can just
tell them i needed a break or
this this is a little different because
this don't turn off
but hopefully this will bring out the
best to me
hopefully this will bring out the best
in
yeah
what part of yourself are you most
scared or embarrassed for the public to
see some of those examples could be for
women it could be you know no makeup in
the morning i don't i don't i don't want
i don't know i don't want these people
to see that i'm a mess maker
and i can't help it damn i've been in
this room
like um
oh yeah yeah a day ago
looks like i've been here for a month
already
i don't really want to i don't really
want to let people know i'm a mess maker
but i'm trying so so hard
it's like following i feel like i'm um
my clothes are clean i know i look good
when i'm dressed but i feel like who was
a little guy over on offer snoopy
where were the dust following
that's how i feel sometimes
i don't wanna i don't wanna i don't want
people to see me like that though
making a mess
you made me laugh there
who would you not want to see walk
through the doors of the celebrity big
brother house who would i not
want to see walk through the door
shannon breaks
you